hey your legal name is cockburn well
actually okay now growing up I cockburn
you know you better be hot you know what
it's like Boy Named Sue it builds
character did guys come up to you in
high school and go hey I want you to
give me cockburn you heard it all what
but you know what it's funny and like I
I laughed as hard as anyone because I
was like hey I get it but it's it's a
Scottish name that actually in Scotland
is is pronounced Coburn which you know
of course who's gonna get that one no
kid who wants to no kid if I'm a kid in
school and I see cockburn you're
cockburn you are not Cobra maybe that
was good for me though because like from
a really young age I was like yeah you
know dealing with that kind of ridicule
is good for you so you choose the name
wild when you become an actress because
you like Oscar Wilde I loved Oscar Wilde
and it was like I'd done
um some Oscar wild plays and I was just
really inspired by his whole story and I
loved the idea of stage names I thought
they were really romantic when you were
19 you break into acting you get a job
on a show called Skin you said the
show's skin on Fox was terrible it's the
worst thing you hate the show you mean
you get a part if you gotta take it
because you're a new actress in
Hollywood but why did you hate skin so
much it was so bad but you know what I
loved Ron Silver remember Ron yeah yeah
he was so great and I got to play his
daughter so we would hang out and we
we'd talk about acting and he was so
smart and then we got political and we
did unfortunately we would have debates
that would like tear us apart but we
loved it because he was a really
Conservative Republican and I oh sorry I
couldn't understand how he had made that
switch because he had been really
liberal in the 70s and the 80s and then
he made a switch hey when you started on
that show um boc uh-huh you played Misha
Barton's lesbian lover right that's
right how was that you're not gay at all
right I'm not you never had gayness in
your personal life no I've always been
really straight I mean I I'm you know
were you freaked out by it uh when they
cast you with that that you don't care
it was funny because I remember meeting
with losers and they asked would I come
on to play like a a manager of a bar and
they the way they lured me they were
like you're gonna see live music every
episode I was like that's great cool and
as a joke I was like listen I'm not
taking the job unless I can make out
with Misha Barton right and they
blanched and they were like did you did
someone leak you the scripts
it was like a such a joke I don't know I
was just like is that awkward because
you're not gay uh you don't know Misha
Barton it's not awkward because it was
so you know sweet we just kissed you
practice that kiss in rehearsal so it's
not awkward on camera I think you save
it so that Sparks Fly on camera I see
foreign